not a cool intro I bet none of my
editing could ever make it that cool
that's right everybody because today's
video is sponsored by like AB which is
how I made this cool intro they also
have now a bunch of superpower abilities
that you can use like fire brain flying
rock lightning Nordic and many many more
it's really cool I definitely recommend
that you guys check it out I was
honestly having such a laugh just trying
them out if you want to make them as
well it's very simple you just place
down the phone wherever it's stable you
move it to the right frame and you just
follow the instructions on the screen
it's all motion based so whatever
emotion you do it follows with the
effects it's really cool it feels like
you actually have the superpower worlds
are doing a giveaway of $10,000
that's right so if you want to know how
to find that you got to keep watching
you can download the like app check out
the link in the description let's get
going with the video everybody man
review everybody welcome to the show
that I I will lose the memes first meme
it's so funny sorry I'm prematurely
laughing you don't even know what meme
it is yet the 15 minutes mean that's
right yes if the army doesn't show up in
15 minutes we're legally allowed to
leave I didn't know this meme
transcended internationals but
international national nations but
basically it's the same in Sweden if the
teacher was late 15 minutes to class
some dips nish me would say oh if the
teacher doesn't arrive in 15 minutes
were allowed to leave this was declared
in 1776 I hereby declare that if their
teacher
get to class in 15 minutes you're
legally allowed to leave it's the Lord
thank you George Washington for wait a
minute that's that's not George
Washington that's visa anything these
days is such a funny meme I never did
this it kind of annoys me I always tried
to get everyone riled up you know like
before a battle like guys come on
it's almost have 15 minutes and if we
all commit to it I can't be the only one
that leaves because then I look like an
idiot
but if we all leave collectively then
we'll be fine
together we are strong and it's bound by
the law guys no one would ever listen to
me if the baby doesn't arrive in 50
minutes we are legally allowed to leave
he makes a fair point
because it's true everyone knows that if
the baby doesn't arrive you don't have
to take custody same sort of mental
exercises gone on through in the egg if
a sperm doesn't arrive in 28 days I am
legally allowed to leave when your
kidnapper takes longer than 15 minutes
to the gas so you're legally allowed to
leave me when I'm about to be executed
via electric chair for manslaughter but
the staff is 50 minutes late so I'm
legally allowed to leave wait harassment
video Ben
damn it before in only 15 minutes Robert
left as he should because it's within
his legality you know doesn't show up
for 15 minutes UK press it they're
legally allowed to leave guys 14 minutes
15 minutes 14 minutes fifth date he's
legally allowed to not race his stupid
family I'm afraid you were 15 minutes
late she was legally allowed to leave by
the law by the stairs
this mean gets a 15 minutes 15 against
15 14 out of 15 it's a great meme it's
clearly dead already
it is it start being funny even when I
did the first one I'm like this really
isn't that great why Lisa well you said
please talk to me please
literally all of my haters all of them
they're always like oh he's memes are
stale
his memes are always late he's the last
one to the mean and quite frankly I
don't find him very funny
Oh Papa that's great that's great that
you think Emily asked you the meme cuz
all the sudden all the sudden I don't
know where the suck meme comes back oh
yeah now it's funny right
right after I invested millions and
billions into the mark suck mean look at
this look at this look when I did this
video 29 of October 2017 and now you're
all posting junk memes oh haha they're
so funny that was Tara I guess you don't
know what I'm talking about affiliated
with the context that's right because
even if you were a normal M
I will enlighten you I care about all my
viewers this is so disturbing how tall
is the person that took this photo these
are the goddamn giant and why is he
taking a photo of some chicken wings and
potato fried us
there's nothing impressive about that
it's not some culinary death dant dish
look at its face
maybe this mean bounced back because
there recently mark has been in there
the media because things aren't going
well for Fayette Facebook 8-billion
looks like Mark just sucked himself am i
right ah this all started because mark
did a he got a question right here it is
you kind of need to remind yourself that
you need to focus and and try not to let
stuff bother you as much as possible but
it is gonna bother you because you're
human and and I was human I am human
still um but
unlike the funny slip-up you may say oh
no no no no no no this is not the first
time it just happened that's right are
the allegations true that you're
secretly a lizard no that's exactly what
a lizard's person would say everyone
knows that everyone so he's either a
robot or a lizard person we don't know
yet but it is either and it cannot be
none of it Mark Zuckerberg is not a
human
I made this meme long ago you're welcome
you're welcome planet Earth it's not a
meme it's science
it's scientific fact just like the fact
that Earth is not round not flat it's a
doughnut wake up it is my high honor to
introduce dr. Mark Zuckerberg oh he
seems so nice right this is how it
sounds if you increase the audio and
find you the frequencies and add five
level of Vulcanus to your Mark
Zuckerberg memes which I think you have
acquired right now doctor you can
clearly hear the robots apps
listen carefully it might not come right
away it's time for some mind games this
is exactly what I wanted all of you
against all of me I'm scared I'm scared
that not enough people I'm actually glad
that people are bringing back this meme
now because it means there is a hope for
mankind after all mock talk about please
stop stop why can't I find a guy like
this huh hey no I'm literally the guy in
the pic oh my god
Morris all--it how much evidence do you
need NASA when I first met mark we were
at some boring corporate party tired of
stupid [ __ ] shed expensive drinks I
pitched an idea to mark each of us would
have come up with the most fun activity
we could imagine and surprise the other
with eight I drove to a nearby lake
ordered to water powered jet packs to
paintball guns in a rage to flight
journey and I figured that nothing could
be more awesome than an airborne
paintball battle with don't stop
believin playing in the background when
I came back to see marks activity I
found him in a back alley next to a
terrified waiter from the party couldn't
even have been older than 25 in exchange
for paying his student loans
MOG excitedly told me the man would let
us beat him until he stopped moving now
that's that just sounds like a good time
if the user doesn't reopen Facebook in
15 minutes I am legally allowed to steal
his/her data that's right and thank you
for using the right pronouns they're
more of your data I gather the more I
understand what it means to be human
like most normal human males
I enjoy charring meat inside of an
unpressurized vessel behind my domicile
there slows for each of browning bird
muscle is associated with patriotism and
mortar shells in my core memory once the
animal carcass that reaches the
temperatures of Asia to destroy their
bacteria and viruses I could pose a
threat to my
I will consume the flesh to replenish my
source of energy I am a sucker Bhagat I
am indeed a human Mark Zuckerberg is
taking classes with behavioral
psychologists to appear more human hey
there
but it is gonna bother you because
you're human and I was human I am human
but I was just referred to myself the
past
it feels like we're the same place and
we're making eye contact it is time for
our generation defining great works
getting people involved by asking
volunteers to share their health data
track their health data and share their
genius new face filters on Instagram
today this is my favorite one so far
nice job team the first place that we
want to go today is we're on a bridge
here I really want to clear my life to
make instead I have to make as few
decisions as possible that's my reason
for wearing a grey t-shirt every day I
was the suck meme gets us me and review
everybody me review that was it that was
it we don't have time for bones meme I
already checked I already talked with
Jerry in the back wasn't that a great
video thank you guys for watching now if
you want to join the giveaway from with
the like app to win $10,000 that's right
ten of you will win a thousand dollars
lucky you all you got to do to enter is
create a video using the superpower
filters using the like app and be sure
to use the hashtag hashtag like
pewdiepie challenge the ten winners were
the best videos using the like app will
win a thousand dollars and will be
announced on Saturday the 14th of April
2018 12 p.m. est baby